do you understand that everybody can
create now at scale at a level that is
so unprecedented there were so many
gatekeepers when you got in the
Hollywood game that had to say yes you
have a chance now we all have a chance
and yet people are still not making
content to live their happiest and dream
filled life out of an anonymous comment
that says they're ugly
[Music]
everybody 321 episode 321 of the
askgaryvee shows and I'm super excited
because you know what's really
interesting is every time I bring up
Brian's name out of you know or if it's
brought up and I talk about knowing him
and liking him or things that nature
it's we were just off air except if
you're on the live and Brad was saying
you know the kids no you know I was like
it's cuz Instagram I was talking about
tick tock there are certain humans that
go around earth that have admiration
from different sectors truly the people
that I most admire for their creativity
in storytelling that are my
contemporaries friends acquaintances if
Brian's ever brought up their reaction
to you and how they admire you and your
storytelling capabilities is is remind
me of what like a 17 year old like
flipper of eBay feels about me so it's a
fun way to start so everybody Brian is
here I'm gonna let him introduce himself
like I always do and then we're gonna
get into a conversation about why he
wrote a book
considering where he's at and what he
felt he wanted to say and then we'll
take a call from instagrams put your
phone numbers in Katie will grab that
but Ryan for a couple people that don't
know who you are on this podcast please
tell them who you are and what you're
about okay
my name is Brian Grazer I accidentally
do business into the storytelling
business
wasn't a plan I didn't really know much
about movies or television at all I grew
a very very very middle-class and a
little cul-de-sac in Sherman Oaks and
now I'm real quick cuz I love to jump in
and they're gonna be mad at me for
cutting you off already what didn't you
play as a 6 to 13 year old like what
kind of kid were you were like sports
were you drawing were you selling were
you lemonade stands washing cards yeah
oh I was so I didn't do lemonade cents I
would sell magazines all types Life
magazine national Geographics like lots
of other kids baseball cards I did a the
valley news and green cheek which was a
newspaper voluntary payment I was
literally delivering papers to get no
payment zero so you have to knock on the
door and go hi my name is Brian Grazer I
deliver your Valley News and green sheet
I know what's voluntary but would you
consider paying me for the month and I
get like 50% of it how much of that
selling in that kind of environment and
you think later help you sell through
ideas Tom Hanks when he learned I
delivered the valley news in green sheet
and because he is a master of all
details he said this is the perfect
thing you're the perfect producer that's
what they have to do sell sell sell sell
sell knowing they're always gonna get
baseline know how are you going to treat
that at a nice business say as a
producer note to me is just a temporary
point of view I'll soon change I love
that so you're not gonna get even it so
if you played sports you sold stuff I
played sports I sold stuff I had
multiple paper outs and I said that just
said I was a champion for the underdog
always probably because I felt like such
an underdog in the classroom itself so
in the classroom I had acute dyslexia I
couldn't read a word so I couldn't
certainly I couldn't read a sentence
none of the words lined up you know
cohesively or sequentially I couldn't
read it all and so therefore it caused
me a lot of shame because I would have
to try to avoid all the sort of shame
that would come with it so I would look
away
when the teacher looked at me so I know
yeah I can't get anyone in the eyes in
class I know that game very well were
you that you know I never was diagnosed
but my ability to consume information
through reading or my ability to read
out loud yes it if you ask me right now
to walk cross street to go to Madison
Square Garden and talking for the 35,000
people on a dime I would do it so easily
if you asked me to read the back of this
ken griffey jr. bit like literally
sitting here right now and saying Don
Drysdale pitched the first no-hitter
friend about like that is like not
comfortable for me and so I very much
understand that and back to your point
never wanting to get called on since I
knew no answers to anything yeah nor did
I ever want to read in class yeah was
something I mastered as well yeah so
probably you did things like invent
having during the bathroom when you knew
it was coming at you that you no
question invented everything - yeah
right okay so we did it up we did
Allison's not going to school at all
like being homesick because I knew there
was an unavoidable situation like a beta
test yes I did all those things suitable
work for you the interesting starting
point to this conversation because I
think right now we live in a parenting
culture that tries to fix everything yes
and I think all the advantages are from
adversity yes me too
I totally agree there's a lot of people
watching right now that yeah you know
listen everyone has their strengths
weaknesses shortcomings happinesses but
like professionally you and I have had
nice runs yeah and I genuinely think a
whole lot of that has to do with not
being good at school first sure I agree
with you period because it causes us to
be self-reliant we're kids now and I
have kids but you know we just they
become disempowered 100% you know what
happens with this empowerment
unhappiness and happen what happens with
happy no I did a depression and so
everybody wants to blame social networks
for all these bad things that are
happening to kids without taking a look
at themselves of how we've completely
made these kids completely not be
accountable and need us for everything
yeah that's a really good point you know
because um you know we kind of know that
we're in this epidemic right now of
loneliness and drugs and no can no human
connection all that stuff but I never
thought of I never really focused it on
the parent
parental side it's the answer my opinion
I think you're right I think we have a
temporary parenting problem yeah that
tells children by our behavior that
you're not capable yeah let me go take
care of this I'm gonna run to school
solve a problem the bully like yes my
wife Veronica was sitting behind by
saying she says I do
unfortunately I bet you do this too I do
this with my employees when I see them
they go I don't know how or what do you
do I just go I'll do it I just do it
I usually are you go do that but I
definitely create entitlement in
different ways which is I'm actually
taking on the core pressures which
eventually I had an interesting period
in this company several years ago where
I had a reset a little bit because I did
create entitlement from not
micromanaging because I don't
micromanage I just I don't hold I don't
create a whole lot of accountability we
just lost a fortune and etext me this
morning that we've lost a lot of money
on this thing we sold and I'm like how
does that possible it was super
profitable he's like like the two people
that were closest to it misjudged what
we were doing with the people that were
shipping with it and like my reaction
and I was even white because I'm really
being trying to be thoughtful about this
I'm like man what makes me awesome is
I'm like cool next right right that make
that's awesome but at some other point
not creating radical candor to the
people that are involved me like hey
like I'm trying to find my balance and
evolution because to your point I'm just
like I got this don't worry it doesn't
have seen anything in the scheme of
things yeah which can lead to
entitlement yeah
what I don't do though which is the
nuance of where we got here is I want
the market to be the market I don't
handhold anybody about anything
I don't do the I'll do this I want them
to do it and I'm willing for the whole
thing to burn to the ground so that they
can understand that that is how it and
that's hard for a lot of people yeah
that would be hard for me yeah that's
the good ear I would like I would like
companies project it's good advice by
the way you know I'm gonna try it I'll
tell you what your advantage is you know
like I'd rather have a major project
completely fail and have it be my loss
so that they understood that they
couldn't do it which is where I know
exactly where you go that's where you're
what's cool about where you're at at
this point is setting it up from the
begin anyway we're gonna
okay there's we still got to the
punchline of where a lot of people like
oh that's that guy yeah how did you know
where to go okay so basically it was
like this couldn't read total avoidance
of people shame everything else the
playground what was I like I protected
kids that were bullied and I protected
one kid I remember at a jump right here
at the jungle gym a kid that was two
years older than me
Tara I was scared of this kid but I
fought him and surprisingly won and I
thought you know what I can do this and
I felt finally felt the feeling of
winning at something so I did a school
like stunned was this I was stunned it
was a massive upset yeah it was a pretty
emotional thing yeah literally the
school was really stunned and I became
like the man I'd be can I really did it
was and that happened all the way
through high school actually and then
kids got really big right you know
what's crazy about that I can't believe
we're talking about this and I decide
tracking even though I promised myself a
winner right now okay I think we need to
bring fighting back I literally brought
this up the other day I did the hand
blog chords I got into the I got into
five actual fights by the time I was in
sixth grade
yeah I don't even nobody fights no
advance no we knew I kids fight it all I
don't know anything I think we need
fighting to come back okay there's
nothing crazy about a little scrap where
somebody wins and loses yeah hey I hear
you because it's all about you it's
about like a you gonna survive or not
survive it's a there's a lot of things
involved like I think we need more
saleyard can meet you at the I mean I
literally you know a lot of comments on
the service I'm very aware uh
I literally was like literally had in
sixth grade against Oded Weinstock
that was the kid's name Oded Weinstein I
didn't mean like it was like a 3:00 p.m.
at Marcos house across from the ice
cream truck and the whole school knew
look the whole day yeah fight was
getting promoted like I was a kid or
something that's very funny that's cool
say oneness big right so I won this big
fight that became served that became a
part of a very big part of my identity
um around a junior high in junior high I
was
to read not well kind of like your
trepidation without reading the baseball
card anyway I was able to read so at
that moment in time I started really
looking at people I did just exactly the
opposite and I started looking at people
and realizing wow I can learn so much
more by actually looking at them so not
only am i reading some stuff which would
be kind of a ancillary sort of
educational tool but the real
educational tool is like face-to-face
communication really being present
looking at someone in the eyes not
staring at them in some weird way not
trying to think of twenty questions but
just like listen having it listening
yeah
like letting that evolve and I found
that by face-to-face human connection
I could ask questions and really learn a
lot when you look at somebody they have
a tendency to trust you they have a
tendency to feel validated as a human
being they have a tendency to feel like
this guy really cares and because of
that people will really let it go that
you'll they'll Allah they will give you
their heart and soul and you give them
your heart and soul and a lot to be
gained so that was the point of why I
wrote this book because I found it I can
already the name of the book the name of
the book is called face to face the art
of human connection and you thought this
is an incredible time because this is
your superpower
learned early and now it's a
countercultural move to a technology
we're like it's so in the zeitgeist
right yeah you knew that so many people
were here and saying oh my god I need
that or my kids need that or my
executives need that because everyone's
demonizing technology yes look I think
it's perfect timing yeah I think they're
so compatible I mean search is very
compatible with human connection because
I don't think you should know nothing
about somebody unless they're unless
you're just needing but I think you know
when you're going out to meet somebody
you should learn some it's proper to
learn something about that human being
you know what's funny about that right I
always say that technology for me is the
gateway drug to the face-to-face oh very
good
I feel similarly and I think that that's
why I think there's a lot of people who
are more old-school who are like you and
I that love face-to-face that completely
[ __ ] on technology you know
either/or I'm like no no I have way more
human interactions yes
then then most people because I use it
but I'm a little bit different I
actually don't research anything on
people I meet for the first time okay I
use social media to meet people we're
gonna talk a little bit and then we'll
have a meeting I like coming in cold
because I like listening and watching
the same way you do and I feel that if I
do reading that I'm taking somebody
else's perspective and I'm already
hedging my own observation yeah based on
somebody's two cents yeah it's amazing
how little I know about most people when
I meet them even very fancy people
because I don't know a whole lot because
I like my I like that restaurant that we
met in the first time of course I've
heard your name but I wouldn't have been
able to know as especially because I
wasn't Holly I didn't know a lot about
the whole Hollywood ecosystem yeah I
liked what I felt yeah that's
interesting which the funny thing okay
first of all I love everything you just
said I think it's an idea it's amazing I
people say how do you you know how have
you started such great talents or given
them a break or how do you pick writers
I mostly pick people just out of their
aura they're energetic aura that to me
is the number one so a litmus test for
me do I feel their energy is that
feeling right and then and then I go
deeper but let's make this fun for the
audience from a Content standpoint yeah
give me some hot takes on first time you
met them the world didn't know who they
were now a lot of people know give me a
couple anecdotal like person and what
you felt in that first meeting jeez okay
well I'm gonna cut back to Isaac Asimov
he's the most prolific science fiction
writer in the world I was dying to meet
Isaac Asimov I met he and his wife I
flew across the country from LA to New
York to meet him I didn't have a lot of
money and within the first five minutes
his wife said dim Isaac I don't think he
knows enough about us I think we should
leave so that wasn't a good situation
but I learned in my case I learned and
so I learned you know that I probably
should I think they might have detected
a truth they bite
detected he doesn't know enough and I'm
probably radiated that that was probably
with living within my aura what was the
context of the meeting well the context
was I was there was a point in my life
through 35 years where I still do this
every two weeks
reach out do a cold call to meet
somebody that's expert anything other
than what I do for a living so it could
be science medicine politics religion
well art what do they think when you
reached out why did they say yes
from your perspective most from your
perspective my perspective is most
people when they're out of alignment you
know like they don't they're their
agendas are out of alignment with yours
they might just revert revert back to
the fact while the guy makes big movies
and therefore it's possible they can
enlargen my message that that's always
sort of late you know where I'm going
with this series of questions the level
of audacity to make that statement yeah
from her yes I'm fascinated by she did
it though it was you know I'm witnessing
yeah yes yes for you I'm always
fascinated by the level of yeah that's
not it's very audacious it's very odd to
say we're leaving correct and it for me
it stems from a seed of insecurity that
leads to that audacious act and I was
more curious of like what could have led
to that what did she think you were
extracting that you know like no no I'm
very fascinated my bad behavior is
really interesting to me yeah because
this thing because I am unbelievably
empathetic to hateful people because the
level of pain that is actually happening
inside to get to bad behavior
is extreme yeah I think we hate on hate
yeah and I'm not pathetic to hate
interesting yeah which is not a very
popular point of view right now everyone
who just wants a fight in our society
and I actually think the unlock to
betterness yeah is to understand why
somebody can even get like why would why
did somebody do that you know the people
that I haven't come across and I came
from a very Eastern European family
there's a lot of dynamics there yeah the
weakest seen the strongest that seems
like a Power Move by her it's a [ __ ]
move by her interesting you're probably
I think it's a weird ear right
yeah will you study a lot of things that
I some things we overlap on and that's
interesting I don't anyway so you learn
from that you took that and so that was
back right that was really bad okay
Norman Lear amazing he just exudes he's
ninety eight years old he exudes
goodness
I met him 40 years ago when he was like
the king of everything and I just had
lunch with him again last week what
about what about somebody that a writer
or an actor producer or whatever that
this was their break that you gave him
the break and what do you see in that
mom Bradley Cooper good that's good
let's go okay so check this out on
Bradley Cooper because he's such a big
deal right I mean he's a you know Oscar
nominee everything anyway Bradley Cooper
can sing so Bradley Cooper uncomfortably
exit what just step in the punch light
so go ahead it was at least 15 years ago
but you know he remembers this super
well and he brought it up to me only
just recently but basically he was late
to a meeting with me and he thought
Brian Grazer like usually horse he's out
of breath he's starving he's in my
office I could tell he's hungry because
I was eating in he was supposed to mean
I'm eating a tuna fish sandwich a giant
one from Nate and Al's and I say why
don't you II have for this he goes no I
go I insist he goes all right thanks he
gobbled it up yeah
now smash cut he's oscar-winning
everything what did you feel in that
meeting I just felt like it was the
humane thing to do he wasn't not from
your person I apologize like what did
you take from it like it I think this
kid's got something or he said something
interesting or who introduced you was
interesting and you were curious about
that I would say that's an interesting
one somebody introduced me or made made
him heightened my awareness to Bradley
Cooper have you been in that random Sex
in the City episode yet oh my god you
like that give me something some people
think is you I am sneakier than people
say oh you get that where does that come
out word
vocabulary I am a weird dude I pick up
random [ __ ] so I don't know I feel like
every cell via that one
so that was one that you recall I just
wanted to meet a big it was a
good-looking white you and Ron Ron
Howard amazing when did you guys me the
reason I partnered with him he had no
there was no evidence he could be a
director really right it was like no
empirical evidence right
I was just yelled out of my window I was
a producer as 26 years old 27 years old
on the Paramount lot I just produced
some really big movies for T V at 25
like one was the 20 hour miniseries on
the 10 commandments so I sort of got
like people were you know thought this
guy's got something so now I've got
something I've got a big office I yell
out the window to see because I see Ron
Howard he's the gut actor and Happiness
yeah yeah yeah yeah nice I think it's
scared him cuz he kind of ran ran away
and and then I called his office said
hey I just called yelled out to Ron
Howard I know this is his office can I
meet and I sort of organized a meeting
he came up to my office like three or
four days later and he just came in I
almost felt like AG like the glow of the
Sun coming in at me close-up like just a
glow of goodness and I thought wow it
was such a unique feeling energetically
to to experience and to accept and I
thought everybody needs goodness I this
is the guy I'm gonna bet on that's
awesome and he would tell it that way
and I bet on the right guy because he he
too became an oscar-winning director and
he's so incredibly gifted but neither
one of us knew that much about it at the
time when is the book out or it's coming
out I'm okay the book comes out and I
think the 17th of September of September
sorry yes the people that have read it
in your inner circle yeah it's always
hard to get inner circle feedback
because it's yeah that's it book has
there been you know one thing that I
knew about us that was similar and we
brought it up here and I remember
leaving the restaurant the first time we
met in and at your house and things in
nature we we are very similar in the way
we read people in that way yes um has
there been anything that somebody that
you would pick up on this if you've seen
it has anybody who's in your inner
circle said something in a unique
way or something unique that has given
you an early insight to something that
you're excited about that you may not
even realize when you were done with the
book does that happen yet yes good where
people go
how'd you wrote a book just like a
pathway to success and I thought I'm
mostly just telling stories that
accessed on icon you have a ghostwriter
I didn't come here's what happens I had
somebody I did and yeah cuz I I've
written five New York Times bestselling
books and stepping land is my
ghostwriter but the way I do it is I
just sit with her for 34 days she
records everything and makes it into
proper get grammar oh yeah not a word in
there is hers
yeah okay so this would happen with us
and I think a lot of people do that like
I do but they're cautious to say they
have a ghostwriter because when we hear
a ghostwriter that's what I thought
before I get it do you think Oh Katie
wrote it and I'm slapping my name on it
like this I literally read and I hate
reading my own books multiple times in
case god forbid there's some word that I
felt like I might have said like
serendipitous and she said randomly so
we had a publishing date and then I said
to my wife you know the publisher likes
that ever people are liking it and
Veronica read it and she said it's gone
I don't think it's very good yeah I have
an expression in making movies cuz every
one of the movies that have flopped that
I've made because I've made flash the
biggest flop from your perspective it
doesn't have to be financially like you
would say you know what [ __ ] financially
I knew there was something special here
I love that you look like oh I'll say it
okay fun with Dick and Jane with Jim
Carrey explain why still made a hundred
million dollars forget about that you
know it was still a hit because I forgot
to show you a liar liar giant I'm aware
and then I did and I want to give us a
case somebody's listening you know here
making Google you got plenty of W well
mostly it's about Jim you know like for
example it just was shitty I mean it was
kind of a shitty idea it was an
old-fashioned idea I guess you know the
you know superstars got excited about
there's no different way yeah and this
is a good I was a banach I use it
as when I say something to my kids they
go we gotta put on Dick and Jane dad and
they know like that's just so
embarrassing to me anyway so Brian real
quick not to interrupt you because I
rationalize well the point is is that
any time I think any time I make a
decision that's a good decision it so
that means that shitty every decision
has to be excellent if it's not
excellent and I go good enough
you're always turns into shitty let me
ask you a random thing any other yes
yeah this is a fun question I really
want you to yeah I hope there's a really
answer to it yeah
what film or show honestly did way
better than you expected it because
we're all humans even in the 100 point
scale you're like oh this is gonna be an
82 and then it was a 130
what was the in Reverse yeah cuz it's
easy to say I [ __ ] this up okay right
yeah works like deeply like you know I
guess you never have to publicly say
like oh [ __ ] this is that big I thought
it was gonna be okay
yep okay okay oh that's so great that's
a really good fish no one's asked me
that question ever
no one very good you're yawning I think
it's you know why cuz it's an
interesting question I know that you
thought things that then did better yeah
I mean it's just the truth it's just the
way it actually works so you want to
know which movie did I think was gonna
not do well or but like it might have
been a hit but but they might've been a
smash hit you thought it was gonna be a
hit it's your biggest one of all time
okay I gotta see again and it was a
b-plus I have a few of those for sure
but I'm gonna give you the biggest one
the biggest one
Apollo 13 because what happened is we
got really into it
Ron Howard Tom Hanks and I and we all
thought these paper one knows the ending
it's how can this do more than forty
million dollars is the number you were
running in your head that was the number
we bet we all wrote on and Pete on a
little piece of paper
the highest number was of the preview
right it was 40 was that yours cuz
you're the most optimistic as a salesman
yeah I knew it go ahead I know what did
like to almost 400 an Oscar we did what
a pillow and but so we were just like
totally shocked dude we didn't realize
it was gonna become like this then why
does we have
if you remember oh yeah of course they
do there because it happened because
there was a 12 little 12 page treatment
the gym level the actual astronaut wrote
I got it and I thought wow this is like
a great story of survival were because
I'm really fascinated with human
capability I thought here these guys
they're all in the level of human
capability level tens all three of them
and this event occurs the challenges
that level 10 and and causes them to
think we are not gonna make it how do we
how do we summon something inside of us
to get us to survive when we don't think
it really exists so I just thought the
world of like human capability with
highly capable men that's what happened
and I thought that was pretty amazing
I'm cool yeah so that's what happened
and it did read me and of course it did
really well but I thought there's no
chance this is gonna do more than 41
minute open December 1897 in July it
happened - I didn't realize this because
we don't plan movies for release times
it was it synced up with NASA's
celebration of the 20th anniversary
which was nice yeah which was nice oh
that that was a [ __ ] and so what do you
then do so she says it [ __ ] and then I
go I don't know what to do I can't
revisit this I can't I hate this thing
yeah yeah yeah she goes I'll help you
and so for a year she plugged in and she
helped me and really did quite a bit is
it easy you know what's crazy about that
like having people plug in I've said
this publicly but I've never really got
all the way I always I always love
talking about how I passed on uber twice
in the angel round and cost myself like
you know half a billion dollars and if
you read my first book crush it that
kind of put me on a map yes uh the only
person I thanked besides my family is
Travis Travis was in between things just
hanging out flying around the country
going to conferences and Vegas with me
and AJ just hanging out and he was like
hey let me read it and truly out of all
my books the only thing that has ever
been affected it's not stuffy land
though she's it without her constructing
there is no books but Travis gave me a
lot of feedback I'm like no but you say
this you say this
and so I understand that dynamic yeah oh
good yeah so that's the one I played out
so is it great it was great like my wife
helped me it was what uh what uh what
are you hoping people get out of it well
I'm hoping that people get out of it
that anyone could do this oh there's a
total solid F student do you think do
you think deeply introverted people
anyone can do this okay keep going
anyone can do this because you don't
have to be in other words what's
stopping people from not being dead if a
Swiss grew up on a public speaking which
you would if you anyone that is people
are terrified of public speaking if you
think to yourself this is a gift this is
an thank the audience be Jedi why do you
think people are scared of public
speaking so much as like one of the
shame shame in front of a lot of people
they're in their fear of being
embarrassed do you think that that gets
to the higher level of the concept of
actually worrying about other people's
judgement yes this is the [ __ ] I'm
spending all my time on that's a really
good so that is most let me give you an
example you and I just creative people
yeah do you understand that kids are
growing up now with tick-tock YouTube
Spotify like do you understand that
everybody can create now yeah I do at a
level that is so unprecedented there
were so many gatekeepers when you got in
the Hollywood game yeah that had to say
yes you have a chance yeah now we all
have a chance and yet people are still
not making content to live their
happiest and dream filled life yeah out
of an anonymous comment that says
they're ugly yeah are you crazy so I'm
thinking a lot about public speaking and
social media because I'm obviously
remarkable at both and and what I
figured out was something quite
ridiculous my over-indexing without
jokes now in both those categories
actually leads to the core superpower
that the DNA in parenting I was given
was which was I have such internal
self-esteem noise from the outside by
the way it's also why that's I have
humility I don't hear the cheering
which allows me to not hear the booing I
believe that parents are over cheering
kids people then become addicted to the
cheering is a great subject which then
leads them to be crippled by the booing
yeah I agree what you just said was
profound I love it I think yes that's
why see the great ones in our in the
media our business they go I don't read
the good ones I don't read the battle I
don't read anything they try they they
the great human beings to me they you
know they're really self actualized ones
they're the ones there's like the way
you just said it's where you're not
reliant upon external validation and I'm
hoping that people care more about their
legacies because it leads to better
micro behavior yes my depth of caring
about what's said about me when I'm dead
actually leads to me being a
dramatically better human while I'm
alive yeah and most people like well I
don't care when I'm dead yeah I do they
want the SH what I think you and I share
this I think we're both pretty good
karma oriented a hundred percent because
I definitely feel like you get the tip
on the jump ball on everything if you're
nice to people the end because I think
because I think because I think there is
nothing target no but you know what's
funny my money I actually and you know
why cuz I know me to that point yeah I
actually think the single most practical
thing I know on earth yeah it's Karma
Wow and most people think it's the
greatest fluffy and review there it is
singularly practical do the right thing
be kind it is so clear to me that that's
how the world works just the physics of
that works I mean it it works that way
for you where the energy is working for
you instead of against you the winds to
your black back that final thoughts what
do you want to leave everybody who's
listening about this very
entrepreneurial and creative crew which
I think really fits listen by the way
there's a little bit tighter than I
wanted to be so I think I'm gonna Brian
are gonna do this again great for
everybody's listening I'm gonna give you
guys a good point a something that I
know my audience is not heard for me
often as you guys know I tend not to
publicly cosign a lot of people mainly
because I don't really know
many people I I do know people but I'm
scared to be like follow this or care
about that because I don't I'm not in
control I've you know I don't know what
to get like but once in a while back to
probably the weirdness of our
relationship like it's so obvious to me
that the same value and I don't know
what you're putting out or what
documentaries have been made of you or
what content you're putting out but for
my audience to Brian's earliest points
we obviously are different like
everybody is I have an intuitive feeling
that something that I bring value to you
the reason you're even listening to this
there's an overlap I will never read
three pages of Brian's book and I easily
know that it could bring a lot of value
to the majority of my audience and
that's not throwing a right hook for my
buddy
I don't think we've seen each other
three [ __ ] four years like really
really warm feelings like this is
bringing value to you I know there's
probably thirty not you that them oh yes
sir you'll be fine whether he sells one
copy or eight billion I have a feeling
that what is attractive and has brought
value to much of my audience
there's probably nuances from a
different perspective or worded
differently that might click at the cost
of 13 to 16 dollars over the [ __ ] the
discount in the Amazon prices so I'm
gonna give that real cosign I have a
funny feeling for a lot of you there's a
build here and for the ones that
actually learn through actually reading
I think this will be a good one thank
you welcome right good I believe that I
really do I really it's very it's opened
up every door for me I've learned
everything can I say something every one
of my movie everything that was
successful in my life came from this
this is actually a little bit weird for
me and I don't know weird kind of like
the world speaking to me I have been
spending a lot of time personally in the
last year realizing that I should be
making film and television and and just
sitting here with you I'm like right if
this is a talent game like this is what
like there's like like in the same
reason he would have been talented at
all the things I ended up doing like I
understand human beings and human truths
and then I will naturally find those
stories I understand why spud Webb story
is a good story it's because it's a
against all odds 5 foot 5 guy and be
like
it's just a bigger story than the apolog
the Apollo parts the literal it's the
gray yes yeah yeah blindside the second
I saw to Mike this is gonna smash a left
tackle [ __ ] football player that's
the stupidest pitch of all time but the
bigger story was obvious it's why Star
Wars is my favorite thing it is the most
universal [ __ ] story which is the
fine line between good and bad it's
thinner than you think
you